Cared from mixed martial arts.com on the podcast and he was talking to me about
this guy that we knew was people think then nine 11 wasn't an inside job.
Most people believe that tower seven fell because of fires because the
government told his father Prescott Bush finance the Nazis though union bank,
that's not a conspiracy theory.
Lead on no shit.
We're looking at a bunch of lights and the Goddamn sky.
You're going to tell me that that light and that light that's 250 a hundred
trillion light years away.
How the fuck did you figure that out?
There's like this sub transmission zone below the third dimension that's just
turned over to the most horrible things.
Just what it resonates too,
and it's trying to get up into the third dimension.
That's just a basic level consciousness to launch into the next levels and
there's a full out war inside the government of guys that like to eat steaks,
drink beer,
and having women versus a bunch of pot bellied pedal Fox and down.
I mean,
he's fucking very,
very high level and he goes in there.
I am.